All right so gave us a fake name again
again not shocked i just don't understand
why he keeps doing this you don't understand i
feel like it's pretty obvious you spoil things
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
spider-man 3 teaser breakdown they finally
revealed the title so there's a bunch of easter
eggs in this they also dropped a bunch of preview
images of actual scenes from the movies so i'll
break those down as well if you're brand new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos this is just the beginning they're still
in the middle of filming the movie right now
tom holland was also recently talking about
what's going on with the andrew garfield and the
tobey maguire stuff too so i'll add that to the
video as well and all the Wandavision connections
doctor strange 2 because doctor strange is going
to show up during the movie as well and we're in
the middle of all the Wandavision reveals were
the last couple of episodes so we find out
how this is actually going to be connected
to the Wandavision series i know people saw this
doodle of the flux capacitor on the whiteboard
here with the title and they're like wait
a minute is there going to be time travel
during spider-man 3 there's a whole lot of stuff
going on in this video so we'll talk about it all
but they finally revealed the official title for
spider-man 3. if you guessed it correctly earlier
pat yourself on the back spider-man no way home
i think some people actually did guess this last
year i seem to recall it floating around in the
predictions that everyone was making the many
many different predictions people were making this
actually wasn't one of my picks but i think it's
a fine title and amy pascal said way back in 2019
when they released spider-man far from home that
spider-man 3 would have home in the title so
we all knew they were going to do another riff
on home and the whole theme of the movie is that
spider-man has been doxxed and framed by mysterio
so everyone from this moment right here when they
reveal that video on the planet would be able to
find out where he lives with aunt may and queens
so there is metaphorically and literally no way
he can go home until he fixes all his problems but
just talking about the easter eggs in this video
first then i'll talk about the preview images
that they also dropped when they were dropping
the fake titles yesterday you probably saw the
fake titles they were posting but as tom holland
is walking out of john watts probable fake office
here i'm assuming this isn't really his office in
the marvel studios offices all the directors that
are working on marvel movies when they're writing
the movie are working on the story or not actually
out filming the movie they keep offices that are
really close in proximity like walking distance to
kevin feige's office at the actual marvel studios
offices at disney the whole reason for that is
that kevin feige himself can walk around and
personally visit all the different writers rooms
in the movies you do see a bunch of dog pictures
on the wall though presumably pictures of john
watts dog no john watts himself though in the
video anywhere because they are in the middle
of filming the movie so he's working like 24
7 while they blow through all those scenes tom
holland said they've actually been in the middle
of filming the biggest action scene that's ever
been filmed in any kind of giant comic book movie
ever and it's taken them an entire month just to
film the scene he said it's going to be one of the
craziest things you'll ever see on screen so post
all your theories about what the final battle of
the movie is going to look like because it sounds
like that's what he's talking about but he walks
out pretending to be all sad because of the jokes
about the fake titles from yesterday that you all
priced on your feeds most of the main cast of
the movie were posting fake titles claiming that
they were the real ones just as a joke to hype
everyone up tom holland posted the spider-man
phone home big e.t joke in spider-man home wrecker
with some of the preview images the real preview
images fake titles yesterday but real scenes
from the movie zendaya posted the spider-man home
depot one that's actually a good one i like that
joke the actor who plays flash thompson posted
this spider-man essay homie one you notice the
t-shirt that tom holland is wearing is another
peter parker style mcu shirt in the same style of
his nerdy joke t-shirts from spider-man homecoming
and spider-man far from home this is just another
joke about solving for x like look here i found
x right here you notice the amazing fantasy number
15 poster on the wall just to remind you in case
you don't know what this video is and you stumbled
on it that it is meant to be a spider-man related
video there are people working in the background
of this office presumably because it is an actual
real office i think on the sony lot because sony
is the one that posted this video but if these
are actual real people and not just extras and
interns that they just had be in the video for
the fun of this they're probably not working
on anything super spoilery they're making a big
joke about spoiling things in the video but there
aren't any super big spoilers in the background
they walk past a foosball table you see all these
party decorations that are up they pass under a
bunch of death signs and then under a bunch of
christmas decorations which i believe is just
a reference to the movie actually coming out in
christmas 2021 and the events of the movie during
the movie itself it will be christmas inside the
mcu they've also been more recent teasers from
the movie more videos and clips from the set more
pictures and easter eggs i've already done videos
for that stuff so i'll post links for them in
the description below you can call the death
signs a reference to everything that's happening
in real life with the virus but also things that
are happening to peter parker in the movie like
everyone is out to get him everyone is out for
spider-man's blood they joke about tom holland
spoiling things in the past like you spoiled the
title of the last movie they're talking about this
video but the whole thing is he didn't do that on
purpose the studio had him do that and they just
made it part of their marketing they've turned
the whole concept of tom hall and spoiling things
into part of their marketing machine so when he's
actually giving away real information is because
sony wants him to give away that information then
they walk past the actual whiteboard which reveals
the real title and then after this they were
careful to hammer that home like seriously no this
is the actual title spider-man no way home but all
over the white board you zoom in enhance they
have all these jokes about the fake titles and
the guesses people had some of them are actually
pretty funny like nope copyright issues with this
one no place like home nope trademarked some of
them are like please no hard pass just clowning on
some of the really bad ideas then i love this aunt
may joke here like the fictional character aunt
may inside the mcu doesn't want peter parker to be
homeschooled so they can't call the title of the
movie spider-man homeschooled there are a bunch of
doodles of chemistry equations spider-man pictures
and other little things in the background like you
see iron man's arc reactor just a reference to his
connection to the iron man character like a lot
of these doodles are just meant to be clever winks
at the actual spider-man character and just
references to previous spider-man things
but just talking about the actual preview images
of the movie the scenes that they released
it's a couple different images of them all in the
same place in this dilapidated building so if it
wasn't clear all these pictures are part of the
same scene but you have all three of them peter
mj and ned leeds inside of what looks like
a really rundown or condemned building doing
some detective work on ned's laptop which has
the this is fine meme sticker on the cover just
another clever reference to the dire circumstances
of peter's situation in the movie everyone is out
to get him both legit law enforcement agencies the
police the fbi and all the sinister six villains
that have been announced for the movie like dr
octopus from the tobey maguire movies an electro
from the andrew garfield amazing spider-man 2
movie there will probably be other villains too
because michael keaton confirmed that he was in
talks to come back as the vulture for the movie
there have been all kinds of other rumors for more
core sinister six villains and spider-man villains
but they're probably just doing sinister
six related detective work forming a plan
ned leads still the man in the chair wearing the
midtown high letterman jacket because the movie
takes place during the christmas holiday they
might be on break from school just addressing
the fact that peter wouldn't be able to go
right back to school after spider-man homecoming
like hey see any cool youtube videos recently dude
oh yeah there was this one i saw with mysterio
in a video where he said that you killed him and
then you're spider-man is that true the way that
tom holland said that they addressed some of that
in the movie is that about half the people believe
the video is true the other half just general
public people think that it's fake but a lot of
people do believe it and it becomes a big problem
they have to solve they were also supposedly just
casting for a special courtroom scene in the movie
so post all your daredevil theories i've already
done a couple videos about the daredevil rumors
about him showing up during the movie for a cameo
spider-man needs to get himself a really good
lawyer fast but i'm guessing that this old rundown
building might just be where peter is hiding
out temporarily from everyone it kind of reminds
me of spider-man's apartment from the tobey
maguire spider-man movies just because it's so
crappy looking except he didn't live in a basement
apartment he actually lived a couple floors up but
the walls all had the same white peeling paint
around them like it looked like his apartment
could fall apart at any moment like he might crash
through the floorboards because it's so run down
you'll get your rent when you fix this door then
in this other preview image everyone has been
trying to look at this shadow on them and trying
to figure out who it is they're looking up at high
based on the fact that they don't look like
they're afraid or in terror they're just more
curious about it it could be doctor strange
because of that orangish yellow glow effect
on them like people are like maybe this is
doctor strange's portal and he's just coming in
or it could just be them looking through the high
windows to the street because this is supposed
to be a basement room that they're in also just
confirming the christmas time setting there's snow
on the floor behind them that you can see like
all that white stuff just snow on the ground and
on the table against the wall in the room so
this really is a condemned building like snow
has actually come in through the windows and is
all over the place the whole thing with doctor
strange in the movie is that he's supposed to be
the big avengers crossover character and something
of a mentor taking over the role that iron man had
in spider-man homecoming the way they talk about
him though it sounds like he's only going to be
in as much of the movie as you saw iron man during
spider-man homecoming like iron man was really
only in maybe like five to ten minutes of that
movie a couple big scenes like one action scene
but because of all the spider-verse rumors and
we know that Wandavision is supposed to help set
up spider-man 3 and doctor strange 2 multiverse of
madness people are just wondering what that says
about the actual plot of the movie like what is
it that Wandavision does to set up spider-man
3 because the biggest thing that Wandavision
is setting up is doctor strange 2 multiverse of
madness this big multiverse marvel phase 4 plot
they just teased all this nexus stuff with scarlet
witch on Wandavision back in the last episode
but because there's too many things that they have
not confirmed about the movie it's all speculation
at this point as to what kind of multiverse plot
happens during the film but it does help kind of
explain how you have the doctor octopus from the
tobey mcguire spider-man movies and the electro
from the amazing spider-man movies appearing in
the film the larger Wandavision connection does
seem like it's them messing with the nexus of all
realities and that creates a bunch of multiverse
chaos that then culminates in doctor strange 2
multiverse of madness it also helps set up the
idea of how alternate versions of spider-man can
show up during one movie like oh okay multiverse
i understand now it makes sense but i'll be
covering all that stuff in my Wandavision episode
8 video posting this friday make sure you have
alerts enabled so you don't miss that and i'll
be doing more spider-man bonus videos as we get
more details about what's happening during the
movie there'll be a new venom 2 trailer pretty
soon too so no worries bunch of big spider-man
related stuff happening this year everyone just
post all your reactions about the title spider-man
no way home and all your theories about the
movie while you wait for everything click here
for my brand new Wandavision episode 8 trailer
video and click here for my full Wandavision
episode 7 video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!